When I started writing the VI series,...
...just because I didn't have confidence in what I was trying to do,...
...I was writing out of the male rules of the form.
So, I made her an orphan.
Today, if I was starting out, I wouldn't make her an orphan,...
...but unconsciously, I didn't like the lone wolf personality maybe,...
...and so, instantly, she began having friends.
So, Lotty is her closest friend in a way but is not an uncritical friend.
She's really like both a friend and sort of a mother too.
You know, she doesn't let VI get away with feeling sorry for herself, sloppy thinking...
...and if VI has her biggest fault is lack of impulse control.
But she's always just diving in and that's where Lotty most often criticizes her.
"You stop and think first."